how should the White House be handling
this situation joining us now is ranking
member of the House Foreign Affairs
committee Texas Congressman Michael
McCall Congressman great to see you what
do you want to see from the White House
on this how should they be responding
they should be responding supporting the
people in China gets the oppressive
Chinese Communist Party regime that is
locking down their entire civilian
population uh it's really fascinating to
me the weak response that came out of
the White House we always support
freedom and democracy over tyranny and
in this case communist China could not
be more tyrannical and we see the
footage of people being beaten and
mothers thrown down with their children
and you know Reagan stood up for these
people uh Voice of America stood up for
the people of Russia over the Soviet
Union that eventually led to the
collapse and what I see is the Emperor
of China chairman XI who made his case
before his Congress to become the
Imperial president is now an emperor
without clothes what I mean is the
people of China he does not have control
over them and we need to do everything
we can to support support them
Congressman a defense department report
released today finding China is
accelerating its nuclear expansion
program amid all of this what is your
reaction to that
well you know I've been briefed on this
in the classified space it's very
alarming where China's headed in terms
of its military and its technology the
Hypersonic weapon was a first
demonstration where they are and the
fact is Sandra is built on the backbone
of American Technology we need to stop
selling this technology to China from
the United States and when I'm chairman
of the Foreign Affairs committee that's
what I intend to do but they are very
Advanced now they are the number one
threat now to the National Security of
the United States in the Free World
is there is would you say that that is a
bipartisan reaction would you say you're
hearing a similar reaction from your
your Democrat colleagues
it should be and I'm asked us a lot
because our committee is very bipartisan
one thing I think we can all agree on is
that China is a threat and it's not in
my words it's not in a you know any
politician's word here all you gotta do
is look at chairman she's language and
what he says in his Hundred Year
Marathon for complete economic and
Military domination of the world and if
we don't uh keep our eye on this if they
move into Taiwan where 90 of the
semiconductor chips Advance are being
manufactured if we look at the South
Pacific he's already signed a security
agreement with the Salomon Islands
remember PT 109 John Kennedy that my
dad's generation liberated and now
they're going to try to take it back and
redraw the mats in the Pacific that the
grace generation liberated you know I we
all had our eyes glued over the past
couple hours watching that World Cup
game where U.S just pulled off Victory
against Iran that game happening in the
middle of rising tensions obviously
Congressman I just want to get your
thoughts on that and the political
hostility that we have seen around those
games
well you know you know it's great Sandra
is the United States just beat Iran
today 1-0 in the World Cup that is
fantastic news it just shows you once
again where it's China Russia North
Korea or Iran this this sort of
censoring Free Speech you know they got
mad at their own players you didn't sing
the Iranian national anthem or the U.S
player that had the Iranian flag without
the Islamic Republic symbol on it China
does this as well they censor people
surveil Russia North Korea Iran they're
all axis of Evil they're all aligned
with each other and we need to stand up
for the people of Iran as well and the
women of Iran who have been so brutally
cracked down upon by the itoa in the
irgc we have to have their back as well
and now the USA will advance to play the
Netherlands in the World Cup knockout
round but thank you very much
Congressman for joining us on all of
that we appreciate your time today sir
thank you hi winner Brian Kilmeade I
want you to do me a favor I want you to
click to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page this is the only way that I
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now